was he uh was he nice to you yeah you
know we never had shits and giggles he
always I think I was too loud for him I
think he likes women that are much more
you know low-key than me but hey I had
nothing to do with him you know I was on
the show I loved working with Julie she
was you know great so professional to
work with great I'm [ __ ] oh hey
interaction so yeah you didn't find
yourself worked up in a physical
attraction to the point of distraction
with bad breath oh yeah I think you had
a bit of ginger Vitus if I remember that
stuff Jim isn't it working with people
with bad breath oh wow that's terrible
is it amazing that you meet somebody
with bad breath and there is nothing
they can do like you will make a
judgment on a person based on them
having bad breath like clearly I'm like
do you suck it's chronic it's tummy
sometimes it's the gum is you know what
does it smell like did you notice it
more than once
oh yeah I think it was gingivitis if I'm
honest but hey people could get it you
know you get it I think sometimes bad
people there's something in their
insides that are just rotting and it
shows itself there's all that
masturbating and his mouth just flicks
off the top and right into the mouth
yeah trust me that does not affect
breasts remember about somebody remember
that November that yeah you guys talk
about it amongst the girls did USA he
has really bad breath yeah yeah oh you
would talk about it not to Julie I would
never ever respect Julie too much you
know and she'll probably hear this and
hate me but I gotta tell the truth I
love Julie Julie's the best you know and
her marriage is her marriage your
and she's standing by him and I do
respect you for it
you know yeah but you just wouldn't you
wouldn't kiss this person if the
opportunity came up I'd rather kiss his
[ __ ] feet
[Laughter]